Joe Biden what's he currently up to I
have this tweet for you from Andrew at
don't walk run he said here's the raw
footage of creepy Joe Biden trying to
sniff slash eat a random Finnish child
no I'm gonna play this video for you
[Music]
hat on the shoulder and he walks away
now the first thing I want to say is
when Biden sees this little kid and
starts doing the Om Nom Nom thing or
whatever and they're all laughing
family member being endearing to a
grandchild I might be like you know
whatever but here's the bigger issue for
one this is a strange guy doing what are
you doing to this kid man that's
inappropriate but also it's it's the
double dip
the double dip watch this clip I'm gonna
go slow after after he moves back he
goes back in and does this very weird
sniff right there look at that slow
motion slow motion and reverse the first
one you can say oh he's just being old
you know family Uncle Joe Grandpa Joe
whatever and then the kid looks
distressed look at the kid's face and he
goes in for an extra sniff
right there sniff what's with the sniff
yo I I
he's sniffing sniffing Joe and he
promised he'd stop you remember this yes
well he doesn't I guarantee you he does
not remember making that promise
the man needs a leash yeah like
just imagine
when you're a kid being any of the
people that have to work on that
campaign anytime he has to go out
anywhere near children and they're just
like you think Usher's a menace yes uh
well Usher may be a menace Biden's a
worse Menace that is for sure so Joe
Biden he you know he goes out early a
few years ago and he's sniffing women
and and squeezing them and yeah like
adults too right yes yes and then
everyone was like hey yo joe you got to
stop he comes out and he's like I'm
sorry I'm just you know um it's an oh
I'm an old man we used to do this stuff
I'm willing to bet when that happened
things like this he goes back and he
gets into the vehicle or whatever and
they're alive 88 miles an hour yeah no
they go Joe you need to stop stiffing
kids and he goes I'm an old man I got
very few things left in life give me
this one wait who is it when they're
like I'm not a pervert I'm Italian
that's like that was Cuomo yeah is there
is there a Biden version I'm a Delaware
man and then Cuomo went on to post a
video of all the time he he
inappropriately touched me the thing
dude I'm the thing is I know there were
women that were like I'm fine with it
I'm fine with it because I know
personally know more than one woman that
said to me yeah I mean it's it's Cuomo
he's fine I don't care that he I'm like
really wow that is insane to me I mean
come on look the average woman they see
Joe Biden and they're Fanning themselves
indeed I mean come on he's a he's a
regular
Humphrey Bogart I'm sure Tara Reid has
nothing but he's a regular Hugh Hefner
who's a who's a celebrity from that era
that would would have been considered
well did you Hefner back in the day was
supposed to be and you're dead just like
Joe wait wait who's that lame guy
Lalane Jacqueline was that his name well
Jacqueline was a fitness one of the
first uh Fitness guys yeah super ripped
you know ladies they loved him you know
he was very in shape yeah Tara Reid
would beg to differ
yeah about yeah I know yeah the Joe
Biden phone call that uh you you got to
make that like the campaign thing
because they talk about how Trump can't
get Suburban women votes because he's
like Grody like lecherous or whatever
just okay well you know play the Biden
game just just you know you you go to a
voter and be like I want you to imagine
Joe Biden he comes up from behind slides
his hands onto your back I'm already
done gives you a little squeeze and then
uh
how do you feel would you like to vote
for him violated
yeah would you like to vote for him I've
never felt more victimized in my life
I I just
I mean it's been years and here we are
once again with a viral video
everybody's sharing it of Joe Biden
sniffing kids yeah well honestly though
like this is only going to get worse
because he's not getting it cognitively
he's not getting better and they're
getting rid of all the drugs in the
white house so he won't be able to close
I doubt they're getting rid of it
they've already made no they're not
getting rid of the drugs they're making
the problems go away so they're not
making the drugs go away
remember give them to him remember when
they said that the drugs may have been
from a journalist that was actually a
warning to the journalists who reported
on it the Secret Service is they look at
the reporter one they're like maybe it
belonged to a journey
the story goes away yeah that's exactly
what happened that at least that's what
I wanted wait wait wait could you
imagine like come on Joe body's what 80
years old now yeah we are gonna get to a
point you know you know they say like
old people are racist because I just
don't care anymore or something like
that like what happens when we get to
that point where they can't control Joe
because he's just so old he just doesn't
care and he's like oh
you know Mike's life expectancy was two
years ago
I got I got nothing you know you can't
hold you got no leverage sounds like
he's on this floor of the senate in 1996
and then do the um what's that Bernie
thing where they just kind of spoke yeah
bring his body around are we gonna burn
it but look look what do you threaten
Joe Biden with they're gonna go at him
and say like look Joe we want you to
make these moves like I'm 80. I'm past
my life expectancy and they're like well
you have a son don't you he's like oh
are you kidding me I'm gonna respond to
a threat to that guy they have to
withhold ice cream that's the only thing
they have over it no no no no
the other way around positive
reinforcement they say okay okay fine
yeah what if we get you some targets and
he's like all right
we'll get you some Ben and Jerry's and
we'll have a clown feed it to you no but
but in all seriousness there's got to
come a point where Joe Biden just there
was that video where I think he was
campaigning in like 2020
and some guy asked him a question and he
just snaps and that's going like what
and I think that's because he's just
like I don't care I'm so done and uh and
he's in this position I I feel like
you know a lot of people have wondered
like why would they try and replace him
in the primary
isn't Joe the Deep State like wouldn't
he just step down voluntarily if they
really wanted someone else and I'm like
yeah maybe he's just gone Rogue maybe
he's just like I'd do whatever I want I
don't care you got nothing over me maybe
they have a schedule and they just told
him wait just hold out until we
announced blah blah blah or whatever you
know and I really don't think that he
has a significant amount of input I
really feel like he's like he's like you
know handlers do the whole deal well
that's what they love about it right
yeah and every time they think about
getting rid of them they look at Kamala
they're like
a couple more kids is fine we'll we'll
keep going it's fine look look at this
this is the prediction market for the
Democrats Joe Biden's at 65 cents he is
the sitting president and incumbent and
there's people a lot of them 35 percent
who think yeah he ain't gonna win Gavin
Newsom you know what it is though which
you got to understand about these
prediction markets there's also a value
bet in that look if I spend 21 cents on
a share of Gavin Newsom that's a that's
nearly a five times return if he gets
the nomination
that's really what it's about I still
think it's fair to consider it should be
100 for Joe Biden the fact that
predicted decided to make a contract on
if he would even be the nominee says a
lot he's the freaking guy that saved
democracy didn't he he came and swooped
in and said yo I'm saving democracy from
the Donald Trump and mega Americans and
ah like he's the one who was was like
the Saving Grace for America right but I
like that saving democracy from Trump
supporters
basically saying like removing them from
the Democratic 100 that's the point like
that like I talk about like maoism and
stuff a lot like that's what he when
they say our democracy the people that
are the deplorables are not included
they are not part of their democracy
that is a distinction between people
that support them and people that don't
it's the same kind of crap that Mao did
too Mao would it was saying in Chinese
but it was the same thing it was our
democracy because they use the same
phrases they use democracy and they talk
about it but under with their
understanding you're it's not a full
democracy unless everybody has an equal
voice not just you know everyone gets a
vote well so I feel like it's the same
thing I feel like what they're basically
saying is our democracy refers to us all
in agreement with each other yes you
guys are not in agreement so we must
remove you from the process 100 that's
why they also laugh at the idea when you
point out the fact that it's not a
democracy that you do live in a
constitutional republic and there are
things that that entails and then they
laugh at that because that's not
actually what they're talking about yep
yep
absolutely like that's that is the the
line that they're using there's so much
stuff again Lynn James Lindsay from uh
new discourses he did a podcast on this
and he went through a speech that Mao
did and that it was translated to
English and then he said look this right
here what that Mao is saying is the
exact same thing that Kamala Harris
means when she says this this right here
that Mal was saying is the exact same
thing when you translate it to English
that the that the that Joe Biden is
saying here so there's this when when I
say that there are communist influence
throughout all of our government it goes
through the bureaucracy all the way up
through actual like DSA members but all
the way to the the presidency there are
some people that repeat the things
knowingly that they're communist things
and there are some people that repeat
them without knowing that they're
repeating communist propaganda but
there's a ton of communist propaganda in
the media right who is it in the media
and in the government who is the CNN
reporter that like they had him change
his shot and there was like a picture of
Mao in his wall do you remember that
like it's in there just like ignore that
that didn't or they they just expect you
to not know
you're looking for this is not the mile
you're looking for yeah Sean's known for
plagiarism so maybe he's consciously
going through and greeting it thinking
it's Chinese nobody will know he said
hey this smile guys all right
come on man thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time